these daily news briefings are
purportedly to keep the nation informed
about the battle against the coronavirus
but invariably the president strays off
message and today he used the forum to
rail against what he described as
congressional abstraction in the
confirmation of government officials and
threatened to adjourn Congress and then
pushed through his nominations during
the recess the Senate should either
fulfill its duty and vote on my nominees
or it should formally adjourn so that I
can make recess appointments we have a
tremendous number of people that have to
come into government and now more so
than ever before because of the virus
and the problem it's a threat against
Congress that no president has made
before perhaps it's never done before
it's never been done before nobody's
even sure if it has but we're going to
do it we need these people here
we need people for this crisis and we
don't want to play any more political
games many in Congress would view this
as an attack against the fundamental
principle on which this country's
democracy is based a system of checks
and balances that separates the powers
of the executive the judiciary and the
legislature it's the latest in a series
of actions that would appear to amount
to an abuse of executive power and
follows a suspension of funding to the
World Health Organization that Congress
had already approved and the insistence
that the president has the right to
order states to follow the guidelines of
the executive in deciding when to lift
the mitigating measures president Trump
says he'll speak to governor's before
announcing new guidelines Thursday
making clear these involve the easing of
restrictions in a number of states but
you already know we'll be opening up
states some states much sooner than
others and we think some of the states
can actually open up before the deadline
of May first and I think that that will
be a very exciting time indeed the
president entered the briefing with
these words big day tomorrow
on this day's evidence it's not clear
whether this is a
promise or a threat Mike Hanna al
Jazeera Washington